It is time for battle of the bites, Donut Edition.
(upbeat music)
(clapping)
The winning donut shop of course will claim
the coveted battle of the bites trophy.
And it doesn't, that's right,
get any better than that.
(laughing)
(victorious music)
Ike, what makes a perfect donut for you?
Ooh. Okay.
What I'm looking for in a donut,
I'm looking for a real nice, soft, moist cake.
I'm looking for any kind of glaze
to have a nice hold on it.
Not when you take a bite,
have it fall off right away
and above anything, I'm looking for flavor.
Well, up first is from your home-town of Chicago.
It's Stan's Donuts.
Hey Drew, I'm Rich Labriola from Stan's Donuts
and coffee in Chicago.
Thanks so much for including us today.
Stan's has 13 locations in Chicago.
We also ship via GoldBelly nationwide.
All the doughnuts are handcrafted,
made with real eggs, butter, and vanilla
and a little bit of love.
Hope you all enjoy it.
(clapping)
Okay. Let's try Stan's Donuts.
Alright we have.
Which one?
The green one.
Oh my Gosh.
This looks like a pistachio, possibly?
Lemon pistachio.
Oh my God.
Oh my Gosh.
(all savoring)
Yeah. This one's all about the texture, right?
It's like crunchy on the outside
but still moist on the inside.
Do-nut let me eat all of these.(laughs)
(laughs) Now I may be an old fashioned kind of guy
but this is like a perfect cake donut.
And I'm not even a pistachio person
but that flavor is just beautiful.
It's beautiful.
Oh my Gosh
It's like you said you wanted cake
but it feels like it's been deep fried.
Yeah.
I'm gonna try the chocolate glaze,
which by the way is giving me
like full blown hostess ding dong vibe.
Yes. I thought that.
I thought ding dong. Here we go.
Oh God it's ding dong-idy good, it's ding dong.
(laughing)
I think the texture is perfection.
Okay. Wow.
Alright. Up next we have hero donuts
from Birmingham, Alabama take a look.
My name is Will Drake.
Founder, owner, Hero donuts.
Hero donuts started from,
honestly from memories of my dad
and I getting fresh hot donuts
every Sunday after church, South Georgia.
Was ready to open up my own business.
Knew that it had to involve donuts.
He we are today.
We have stores in Birmingham, Atlanta,
one in Charleston within a couple months.
We source all our ingredients.
There's no donut mixes.
We make everything from scratch.
They're fluffy and they're awesome. (chuckles)
(clapping)
Okay. I feel like I might need to take a bite of both.
Like the chocolatey sprinkle one
and this like great glazed cruller thing.
What are these?
Does anyone know?
Well I can tell you this.
This is for sure some kind of fritter.
This is like an apple fritter.
Maybe I'm gonna take a bite of it right now.
This is the chocolate glazed.
Oh my God.
(laughing)
(all savoring)
Oh my God.
Oh God the apple. Oh did you get the Apple?
The apple fritter is incredible.
Oh my God.
The burst of the fresh fruit in there. So good.
I'm going to chocolate town real quick. Hold on.
Okay. We'll see you there.
I went to chocolate town,
and it was like that kid's birthday cake feel
where it's like sometimes when you go too fancy,
you can never stay that tried and true,
they nail it with this.
These are incredible, Hero donuts is amazing.
Alright, we're gonna go to Guru Donuts
last but not least.
We've got Guru Donuts from Boise, Idaho.
I love Idaho, take a look.
Guru Donuts started out of a garage
with a donut fryer and a dream, "To serve others
and create community through the joy
of the shared donut experience."
We are proud to be a woman-owned and women-led business.
And value creating a fun
and welcoming environment for everyone.
We know you're gonna love our donuts
because our motto is, "Donuts for all."
We make vegan and gluten-friendly options
including our Idaho potato donut.
Our donuts are made with real ingredients you can pronounce.
Locally sourced, nothing artificial.
We mix, cut, fry and glaze each donut
by hand every morning.
No shortcuts.
(somber music)
(clapping)
I'm so excited, Idaho potato what?
What? And do you see this donut is a square donut?
Breaking the rules.
And it's called "The Winnie the Pooh."
(laughing)
That's the Winnie the Pooh, Ike.
Should we try it?
Yes. Very much so
Never had a square donut.
Oh my God.
Oh
Yeah I know.
Oh my God.
Whoa. I was not expecting this.
Very doughy.
Very bready,
but very moist.
Not dry whatsoever.
No and complex.
Complex. It's not too sweet.
It's like a buttermilk biscuit
and a donut had sex and made this beautiful child.
(laughing)
And then this one is the mango tango.
Okay this one.
Oh my God.
Oh I know, there's cinnamon.
The mango tango cinnamon, Ike.
What do you think?
Did you try that one?
I just took a bite of that mango.
I've never had a mango donut.
I feel alive.
(laughing)
Wait, this is the gluten free one
with the potato flour, hold on.
Alright. This one right here, this guy.
Whoa.
Oh my God.
I think kids would love this.
It's like very sprinkly sparkly candy
like you're eating like candy diamonds.
Okay guys.
Now it comes time to vote.
One at a time we're gonna reveal our favorites.
Alright, ready?
I'm gonna go first.
A one, a two, a three.
Whoa.
Okay.
(clapping)
I'm gonna go second.
I'm gonna vote for,
Guru's.
Yeah, uh huh.
Chicago, Idaho. Ike what do you got?
I gotta say Guru, Hero,
They were so good but at the end of the day,
if I'm picking one,
I'm picking Stan's Donuts baby.
(all cheering)
(victorious music)
Well we have a winner then.
And our winner is Stan's Donuts.
(clapping)
(laughs)
The music.
And look what I love, Ike,
is that Stan's is in Chicago,
which is your hometown.
I know.
Ike Barinholtz, you are just incredible.
And I'm so excited for your new movie,
Moxie directed by the phenomenal Amy Poehler
is available right now on Netflix.
Thank you so much for coming,
you made the show so much better
and thank you to Stan's donuts in Chicago,
our battle of the bites winner.
(upbeat music)